ce que je peux faire goûter un nouveau
produit que nous lançons sur le marché
allez-y un yaourt aux fruits
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je veux dire à mon patron
oui c'est sûrement
mais c'est parce que vous n'avez pas
pris de morceaux avec les morceaux c'est
beaucoup plus onctueux regardez
gros gros morceau ouh là là
c'est bon
faut finir
moule
alors
le premier yaourt aux fruits de mer avec
des vrais morceaux de fruits de merde
dedans
c'est pas bon
qu'est-ce qui vous gêne c'est des
morceaux
[Musique]
pour maigrir il y a pas mieux parce que
direct on va à la selle
c'est pour aller à la selle ou vomir
voilà ce sera mieux que votre menu
minceur c'est gerbey qui fait ça
[Musique]